don lemon is the cnn anchor who thinks
that america hates
black people and america doesn't hate
black people and we fought a civil war
to end slavery we had a black president
most countries in europe that are way
older than us never had black prime
ministers
and we've done things over the years to
heal the legacy of racism and that is
not to say
that things are perfect but that dream
that that mlk guy wanted about
uh the arc of justice bending towards
more equality it's kind of here and
we don't have laws that discriminate
although the leftists are actually
instituting some of those laws
but anyway lemon is an interesting
character because he is race-baiting in
the worst possible way while telling you
that america hates black people and
hates gay black people specifically
he a gay black man is making around 4
million bucks at cnn to go on every
night and pontificate and get the rest
of you
ginned up about racism now again this
gets to this thing about how much time
should we focus on msnbc and cnn and
washington and new york times
because they're all sort of failing at
some level
but i do think it's important to call
these people out and expose them for
what they are
but in this video i'm going to let i'm
going to let lemon expose himself so in
2014 this is only
seven years ago he had a really
interesting
sit down with morgan freeman and i want
you to listen to this
not only don but really listen to what
morgan freeman is saying
about race and then the second clip will
really reference
this thing that's happened in the last
couple days so take a look but it's hard
to
when you say that to some people because
they say oh there you go with it pull
yourself up by the bootstraps
thing and you know you're just being
respectable not everybody can do that
everybody can
everybody doesn't courage
courage is the key to life itself
there are a lot of people who are born
in situations if i just i'll never get
out of this
so they won't i say to
people who say well i i would like to
have done so and so and so
somebody could have done it so well i
couldn't get out of here
man the bus runs every day
you're exactly right yeah [ __ ]
everybody can yeah that's right morgan
freeman and by the way don lemon is sort
of acting as
the devil's advocate in the question
he's not even saying that he agrees that
people can't lift themselves up by the
bootstrap and by the end
he's agreeing with morgan freeman right
like that's
that's pretty powerful stuff uh but now
let's listen to what don lemon was
saying to his colleagues
about racism on cnn back in
2014. i thought what you said was
fascinating because you called it bull
when you said people can't you know
pull themselves up do you think that
race plays a part in
wealth just distribution or either a
mindset that you can't
yeah no you don't no i don't i know
you and i we're proof why would race
have anything to do with it
stick you put your mind to what you want
to do and go for that
uh it's kind of like
religion to me it's a good excuse for
not getting there
you know i said and it's probably get me
in trouble but i said
to some of my colleagues recently saying
so i know that it's an issue
but i've been it seems like every single
day on television i'm talking about race
and it's because of the new cycle it's
in the news but
sometimes i get so tired of talking
about it i want to i want to just go
this is over can we
move on and if you talk about it it
exists right
it's not like it exists and we refuse to
talk about it
but making it a bigger issue
than it needs to be is the problem we
have
man morgan freeman that's it right there
making it the bigger issue
endlessly talking about it and lemon is
saying seven years ago i'm sick of
talking
about this and in the previous clip
morgan standing
were proof that you as a black man can
do anything in america
right so you're actually lemon you're
delegitimizing your own existence as a
black man as a gay man whatever it is
like it's actually insane the the quote
there
lemon sometimes i get so tired of
talking about it
i want to just go this is over can we
move on
so in two let me understand this in 2014
don lemon is saying that racism is over
can we just move on and seven years
later he's saying america
doesn't like black men or particularly
gay black men and that is complete
nonsense you don lemon and your silly
little friends
at cnn are keeping racism on life
support which is exactly what morgan
freeman is saying there you can always
talk about it and if you always talk
about it you will always keep it going
and now because of that scary critical
race theory thing that you think none of
us can
define even though we define it all the
time you guys are the ones that are
making
america more racist there
where please somebody show me someone on
the right i don't mean some
loser twitter troll with a green frog
avatar
i'm talking about show me someone
mainstream on the right a senator
a congressman someone who is
racist and is trying to put racism into
the system and wants there to be
different laws
for black people or doesn't want black
people to succeed let's not forget
congressional black caucus
sitting there like this as donald trump
during the state of the union
said that we had all-time low black
unemployment and i thought that would be
something they were for
but they decided they were less for that
rather than mostly they were just
against
orange man so you know look we can all
change
right i've changed we can all evolve we
can all get new information
and and look at the world in a different
way but the way
that don lemon is evolving is not
evolution
it's devolution right he's devolving in
his in the in the thinking
right racism is over i want to tell my
friends and my colleagues
you know we shouldn't talk about this
anymore let's move on and now it's
we got to talk about it endlessly all
the time it's never enough and if i'm
not mistaken
he just wrote a book about it too like
lori lori people